[Music]
sea turtles are miraculous first they've
been around since the late Jurassic
roughly a hundred and fifty million
years ago cohorts of the dinosaurs sea
turtles have survived through the
challenges of eons existing still today
where many others have ended their
evolutionary run second throughout the
centuries and up till today
every living adult sea turtle has
overcome the odds existing as a
consequence of chance skill and
capability the gauntlet
each sea turtle faces in the course of
its lifetime goes thus first deposit as
a clutch of leathery ping-pong ball
sized eggs into a nesting pit dug by its
mother high on the beach of the 50 to
200 eggs laid roughly 20% will never
hatch roughly a month and a half after
having been laid there surviving eggs
hatch and the young turtles each small
enough to fit in the palm of your hand
squirm to the surface emerging from the
sand in mass and making their desperate
Dash for the sea along the way debris
pitfalls crabs gulls raccoons and other
threats will claim roughly 50% of those
who rose from the sand for those that
actually reach the surf they trade one
set of threats for another as they first
face the repelling force of the waves
and then find a whole new host of
predators awaiting them various fish
dolphins sharks and seabirds as the
young turtles come to the surface for
air for their first few days of life
should they count themselves amongst the
living the vulnerable turtles swim
frantically forward ultimately they will
often look to settle in a patch of
flotsam preferably a patch of floating
seaweed now for the next several months
they will seek to avoid those that would
eat them find that which they might eat
themselves and not fall to the pressures
of challenging weather or unfortunate
currents in this phase roughly 50% of
those who reach the surf will perish
ultimately with the passage of years the
survivors will increase in size from
that of a dinner plate at year one to
that of a dinner table in the case of
one species at least the leatherback a
decade or so later with size comes some
of protection the only truly worrisome
Predators now are some of the larger
shark species bulls Tigers and whites
and the occasional killer whale at
approximately two decades of age the
survivors will be old enough themselves
to breed and continue the cycle which
their very existence heralds of those
that began as eggs on a distant Beach
now less than 10% remain at least those
are the odds prior to significant human
interference over the past century and
in particular in the last several
decades human endeavors from beach
development to plastic refuse to
poaching long lines nets and even
noxious chemicals including oil have
upped the ante for sea turtles causing
their survival rate to drop to around 1%
or less from each nesting cycle it is
this added human pressure which has
pushed each of the eight sea turtle
species into either a threatened or
endangered State for a while they have
evolved to overcome a host of obstacles
the most recent has arisen so quickly
and at such scale that the species find
themselves overwhelmed so let's quickly
recap this cycle of odds using a
hypothetical nesting season for females
may nest multiple times in a single year
of a thousand eggs for sake of ease one
thousand eggs laid eight hundred hatch
four hundred make it to the water 200
progressed toward adulthood twenty
survived to breeding age that is without
human interference to survive to
breeding age with human interference so
a breeding adult sea turtle is the very
embodiment of a long shot it is the
exception not the rule a jackpot it is
in a very real sense a miracle
you